why wait in line there's plenty of  demand at the nevada dmv  branches but the department is  encouraging you to try and take your  business online  many customers are waiting months to get  an appointment these days  but most tasks can be done with the  world wide web  at a dmv kiosk or by mail if you just  moved here and you have to register your  car  or if you bought from a private party  you do have to register for that in  person  but while you wait for an appointment  don't forget you can get a movement  permit instead  those are issued for 60 days for a  maximum of 180 days you have a little  leeway there  you can also renew your license online